[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie new
spider-man promo and they give us a much
better look at the new Ironman armor its
mark 47 whole bunch of Marvel stuff
happening today there's a new spider-man
giveaway happening all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so there's a couple things
that don't appear in that promo that the
suit can do but all the stuff they've
explained so far about the students
shown off in these types of promos is
the stuff that we've seen in the trailer
so far the one thing it has that we
haven't seen yet is an AI just like Tony
Stark's suit now as of the end of age of
Ultron Tony Stark has been using the
Friday AI system in his Iron Man armors
but he also has the Jocasta memory stick
here there are several others it could
be any one of these or it could be a new
one I have a feeling that it'll be
something with a certain level of
significance to spider-man's character I
know a lot of you are hoping that its
name been just an AI week - Uncle Ben
who they're kind of sidestepping in the
movie without completely cutting his
story out you can't do spider-man
without Uncle Ben but you don't
necessarily have to show that scene over
and over again like you don't have to
see Bruce Wayne's parents get killed in
Crime Alley every time you see a Batman
movie we learn about the Back to the
Future sneaker style autofit technology
that's one of my favorite things about
the suit just as a joke they actually
sold a version of those in real life you
just stick them on the laces will
tighten - however big your feet are so
shrink wrap spider-man's suit will just
conform to however big he gets and he's
a teenager so yeah I mean he's gonna
grow a little bit but I think the idea
is is that down the road if he bulks up
big time then they won't have to
automatically resize the suit it's like
a one-size-fits-all type of suit we
haven't seen much from the drone they
demo here we've always seen it detached
from a suit we've never seen it actually
collect information and send it into the
AI system because everybody's wondering
if they're going to break with past
tradition and actually show you what it
looks like inside spider-man's mask the
way they show you what it looks like
inside iron man's helmet that was one of
the coolest things when that first Iron
Man movie came out you guys couldn't let
me know how you feel about that
typically it's something spider-man
movies have avoided because it's always
been a cloth version so you don't really
need to see inside the mask but because
this is stark tech there's irises that
resize depending on what he wants to
look at or focus on or how much light he
wants to
allow in and now he's going to be
getting a whole bunch of extra data but
it looks like a lot of that is also
processed through his gauntlets - you
see a better picture of it here when
nedley's is playing around with the mass
like this funny scene he has like this
big hologram pop up from the gauntlet
most of the information that the suit
collects will probably just be read out
in that form just because 3d holograms
look really cool because there's so much
Iron Man in this movie I think they want
to avoid trying to turn it into an
outright Iron Man movie that just has a
lot of spider-man in it that's been one
of the complaints about the trailers so
far is that there's so much Iron Man
being such a big part of the story but I
think you'll be surprised by his
presence in the film yes they're relying
on him heavily for some of the big plot
elements but at its core spider-man's
journey is the engine that drives the
film so the grenade wedding is really
cool but we got to talk about the
version of the Iron Man costume that
he's getting in this movie so this is
clearly the ultimate Iron Man costume
they're borrowing a lot of ultimate
spider-man elements from that comic book
for the characters like medleys here is
very clearly a version of Genki Michelle
Gonzales could be who this character is
they were calling her Michelle a lot of
people think that she might be Mary Jane
in disguise and they're just using a
fake name that's all speculation for now
we'll just assume that she's a version
of Michelle and they're just borrowing a
lot of things from the comics so that it
looks very different from spider-man
films that have come before that was
really like their number one thing do
things that we've never done before
so that's mostly the much younger
setting much younger version of the
character in the villains that they pick
so what they're calling this is the mark
49 armor it's just silver and red
instead of being gold and red and
obviously the different armors have
slightly different functions for now
we'll call this the Spiderman rescue
armor
spider-man messed up big-time we need to
help save him so you see all these
drones pop out during this big fairy
save those look like they come off of
the armor so they're just one of the
additional functions that his previous
armors didn't have so typically when he
does get new armor it's just in service
of whatever the plot needs of him to do
so like during Iron Man 3 when you saw
billions and billions of armor it was
just really like meant to be a funny
throwaway saying like Tony Stark got
super crazy in his basement when all
Howard Hughes and made all these
specific armors for very specific
functions like the egor one was for
heavy lifting he had modular armor
he had the Heatseeker armor he had speed
armors we haven't seen this dealt armor
yet there was the space armor that we
got a teaser for that was a bit of a
misdirect so I'm hoping that when we get
to infinity war we see like another Iron
Man 3 style shot with a bunch of
different armors even though he's
probably only going to wear one or two
different suits but I know it's kind of
hard to tell just looking from the
trailer if you wondered this silver is
not vibranium black panther wouldn't
give that up that easily
and he hasn't joined the Avengers yet
that was a big question after I posted
my Black Panther video is he part of the
Avengers now because they did kind of
work together
technically no I think it'll be a
version of the way he joined in the
comics so what happened in the comics
was when Black Panther first came around
he joined the Avengers just to make sure
that they weren't a threat to his
homeland of Wakanda because of a lot of
the same reasons that they start Civil
War with like look at all these terrible
collateral damage situations that you
caused sokovia the Battle of New York
people get hurt wherever you go even
though you're trying to do good things
so Black Panther sees this happening and
people are using vibranium to try and
create adamantium the funny thing about
adamantium in the Marvel comics I know
they don't have it in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but when they were
originally trying to create adamantium
they were really trying to replicate
vibranium and they created adamantium
accidentally so adamantium is a
vibranium alloy that's why it's so
strong they say it's indestructible but
that's mostly specific to the x-men
universe the best way to think about it
is that vibranium is a stronger metal
it's made to nullify all force that hits
it but technically adamantium
is more durable and then you talk about
guru metal so that's the Thor comic so
that's completely different too so irune
metal versus adamantium versus vibranium
would be a really good fight in the
Marvel Universe if they can ever get
Fantastic Four x-men crossover but like
I said Black Panther in the comics when
he first met the Avengers was very
mistrustful of them he has not changed
his stance since the end of civil war
but he is open to treating with other
nations they've opened up their borders
that was the whole point of Black
Panthers Father's storyline and civil
war before he was killed so even if
Black Panther does like some of the
other characters and is open to the idea
of
working with them he is not officially
joined anybody's team yet and there's no
way he'd allow their most precious
resource into the hands of someone that
he didn't trust completely and I don't
think that he trusts Tony Stark
completely I think they're saving that
for infinity war I'm really hoping for a
Nick Fury Iron Man 1 Avenger style
post-credit scene during the Black
Panther movie where Tony Stark comes to
invite Black Panther to join the
Avengers because they've already
confirmed that Iron Man is going to be
the one to see the threat of Santos and
the infinity gems and he has to bring
everybody together even though they've
split apart since the end of civil war
so there's going to be somebody to go
ask Black Panther to come be part of
their special Avengers Club it's going
to be Tony Stark but just do not hold
your breath for the other Avengers
characters getting vibranium variants of
their costumes now there was the time
during fear itself where they got the
ARU variants of all their costumes that
was badass
guru iron man armor guru spider-man
armor maybe eventually Thor can help out
with that and I know we've been talking
about Avengers for Kevin Feige says as
the title of that is a secret because
it's a spoiler for the first infinity
war film so I'll probably do a video for
that a lot of you have asked for me to
do a comic book video about Marvel
legacy and how it's bringing back all
its old characters there's a whole bunch
of craziness happening in the comics
that has nothing to do with what's
happening in the movie so if you do want
me to do comic book Marvel videos just
let me know in the comments but I'll
announce the winner or that spider-man
giveaway the next time I post a Marvel
video there's going to be some new flash
dropping tomorrow so everybody make sure
you check it out while you wait for that
click here for my non-spoilery guardians
of the galaxy to review and you can
click here for a brand new black panther
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video